the end of the world talking fish heads
and the scariest thing to come out of
sweden since the meatballs at ikea
the umbrella academy season 2 is here
and there's a lot to talk about in this
video we'll be going over the ending and
explaining some of the season's most
unanswered questions
including theories for season 3 like
what on earth
or space is reginald hargreaves what is
this sparrow academy and how this scene
from season 1
may hold the key to those supernatural
powers but before we begin
make sure to like and subscribe with
that bell on because here
we go the final episode begins with a
flashback of
arguably one of umbrella academy's
darkest days the death of ben in the
year 2006
instead of offering words of comfort
reginald blames ben's death on the kids
using it as a
learning experience for them to train
harder and do
better so it doesn't happen again
despite years of training and weeks of
preparation you allowed number six to
die on this mission
i don't think he'll be winning father of
the year anytime soon klaus who has the
ability to communicate with the dead
uses his power to make ben reappear
convincing him to stay with him the land
of the living instead of walking toward
the light into what is conceivably
heaven klaus has long held himself
responsible for ben sting instead of
going off to the next life
but as we learn in the previous episode
when ben whispers something into vania's
ear
it wasn't klaus who made ben stay ben
was just scared of going toward the
light
something he overcomes when he literally
goes toward the light to save vania and
ascends to the afterlife in the process
but don't count ben out or any other
dead characters for that matter as we
see in the final scene the opening of
alternate timelines
could mean the return of characters like
the handler or
hazel but we'll get into that in a bit
back in present day i mean
1963 the umbrella academy is on the run
after authorities believe they're
involved with the assassination of john
f
kennedy most of the season has revolved
around this particular
incident when diego gains access to the
infinite switchboard he finds out that
in this timeline
vanya causes an explosion in the fbi
building that almost kills
jfk now the americans think this was an
attack by the russians and retaliates
setting in motion a nuclear holocaust
that we see happening at the beginning
of episode 1.
that's what this season is all about
preventing another apocalypse and
getting the academy back to their
original timeline
and while this season is about that on
the surface it's equally about learning
to put
family first not only are all the
members of the academy
physically torn apart from each other at
the beginning of this season
so too are they emotionally in episode 1
diego says this
i'm a lone wolf i don't bring mud back
klaus pushes people away including ben
nobody needs your [ __ ] klaus
that's why you're always alone and
luther wants to be alone because he
believes every time he helps it only
leads to more pain
we have to find the others because the
world ends again
in 10 days i don't give a [ __ ] if the
team is going to stop the apocalypse
they'll need to overcome their flaws and
work together
and this all comes to a head in the
final episode where vania asks her
family to help save harlan
the young boy who has seemingly
manifested supernatural
powers now this is where things get
really interesting in episode 4 harlan
nearly drowns but is saved by vania when
she performs cpr
in the process these small orange balls
of energy are transferred from vania to
harlan and i couldn't help but think
they look oddly like those floating orbs
reginald releases
shortly after the death of his wife now
to give some context here the final
episode of season 1 sees reginald saying
goodbye to his dying wife in the distant
past we aren't sure how long ago this
was it could be
hundreds if not thousands of years
likely on some other planet as their
species evacuates and when his wife dies
he releases these orbs into the air
but what is it well here's what we do
know they can give life to the dead and
that vania has them in her body
when she later saves harlan that energy
is once again
brought back into her we don't know if
any of the other academy members
have this energy within them we do know
that there is likely some connection
between
reginald's wife and vania because in
that very same scene
the wife requests reginald bring her her
violin which she says to give to someone
special
that person will later be vania who
becomes a famous violinist
this energy also seems to give or at
least trigger one's innate superhero
power
harlan prior to getting the energy does
not possess any power yet afterward he
does
and after vina sucks that energy back up
we see him
able to levitate one of his toys his
powers remain
will we see vania do this to others and
can she use this power to bring
others back to life that'll be a
question for next season
the family decides to help vanya and
upon arriving at sissy's farm they find
harlan
unable to control his power [ __ ] even
holds a gun to vania thinking she did
something to her a boy
but vania says we are not the monsters
that they say we are we
did not kill the president we are not
terrorists we're not here to hurt anyone
and that's part of vania's character arc
this season she has come to terms with
who she is
not just in terms of her power but also
sexually
reginald treated her like a monster and
suppressed her powers with drugs
carl treats her like a monster because
she's bisexual
it isn't until ben gives her a
heartwarming speech which i personally
thought was the most
heartwarming scene of the entire season
that vanya learns she
isn't a monster after all meanwhile lila
and the handler show up on the farm the
handler who is now the head of the
commission has manipulated lyla into
thinking five
killed her parents well he did but she
left out the important detail that it
was her who oversaw the mission
and had it done so she could raise lila
who she knew had extraordinary powers
as we soon find out lila has arguably
one of the strongest powers we've seen
yet
the ability to mimic the power of those
around her
she can take on luther's strength fives
teleportation
and even vania's energy blasts as an
aside over the course of the season
we've seen the powers of the academy
children
improve as well for example diego is
able to stop
all these bullets and as glimpsed in
episode 1
klaus can control the dead to fight
alongside him
these open up cool new possibilities for
next season
lila's powers call into question the
presence of other such superhero
children
remember that the umbrella kids were all
born on the same day
at the same exact time to mothers who
weren't pregnant when the day began
there were 43 such cases yet reginald
was only able to adopt seven of them
that's 36 other kids with potential
powers we don't know
well i guess with lila it now makes 35
then we also have harlan who wasn't one
of the children born in 89.
he has powers now so my theory is that
this all has something to do with energy
transference like those orange balls and
that reginald knows far more about this
than he's leading on
lana takes on five and learns that the
handler was the one pulling the strings
over her parents death
she never cared about your parents she
was looking for you
diego even tries to convince lila that
they can be her new family
i know that we can be your family
if you just let us this is a big change
for diego who at the beginning of the
season
referred to himself as a lone wolf and
it really looks like lila is going to
join the academy until the handler comes
in and
brutally murders them all even killing
lila who asks her if she ever really
loved her
the handler is then shot by the last
remaining swede who wants revenge for
being manipulated by her
if you recall earlier in the season the
handler was sending the swedes
fake messages from the commission that
she handcrafted herself
which would result in the deaths of the
swede's other two brothers
and it looks like this would be the end
of the umbrella academy if it weren't
for five who remembers a line from his
father
start small seconds
not decades five is able to go back in
time
right before the handler shoots them all
causing a chain of events that leads to
lila escaping using the briefcase
and the handler being shot by the swede
two interesting things here
one the swede doesn't kill any of the
academy and this likely has to do with
this swedish saying
erga for erga or eye for an eye he got
his revenge on the person who
orchestrated the deaths of his brothers
he got his eye for an eye it's also
pretty funny that he ends up hitching a
ride with klaus's cult
destiny's children named after destiny's
child
number two is lila i can pretty much
guarantee this won't be the last we see
of her as she'll likely be in that same
alternate timeline the academy ends up
at the end of the season
plus her powers have way too much story
potential especially if we start
encountering new
more powerful heroes herb sees all these
dead bodies and i can't help but think
that's going to be one hell of a cleanup
he's the new acting chairperson of the
commission
until a new board of directors is
elected so this looks like there will be
a much more amicable relationship
between the commission and the umbrella
academy going into the future
speaking of the future [ __ ] tells vania
that she and harlan won't go with her to
2019
and that's because vania can't promise
harlan a normal life or that he'll even
be safe who knows what dangers the
future will hold who will come after
vania
and [ __ ] can't have that around her
child even allison says goodbye to her
husband ray
which i thought was the weakest of the
goodbyes she basically says she doesn't
belong in 1963 in a letter and just
bounces
poor ray klaus learns to let go of dave
who in this timeline he'll never fall in
love with in vietnam
and here we see jack ruby luthor's boss
of the club
pick up a gun presumably to shoot lee
harvey oswald the man who shot jfk
who he actually killed in real life the
umbrella academy ends the season
just as they ended season 1 going
through time together
they arrive on april 2nd 2019 the day
after the original apocalypse back at
the academy
but they soon discover things aren't
what they seem
reginald is alive and well even
remembering them from the 60s
a photo of ben is on the mantelpiece
instead of five
and the academy is no longer the
umbrella academy
rather the sparrow academy it seems
their foray into time travel has
completely
changed the timeline but this final
scene gives us valuable clues as to what
we can expect from season three
having reginald back in the picture
opens up massive potential for learning
more about his alien origin
and how that origin relates to the
academy's powers
there's also the question of other
aliens if reginald made it to earth is
it not possible there are others
and the fact 56 years have passed since
the events of 1963
mean we could see old characters pop up
including rey [ __ ] but
more likely harlan in fact van his
connection to harlan almost undoubtedly
means he'll make a return
but the question is will he be in his
70s if they meet again since
harlan would have grown up and the year
is now 2019.
another huge factor is five now having a
better hold on his ability to travel
back in time he did it at the end of the
season
will he do it again and in what capacity
then there's the whole question of
old five who traveled back to the
original timeline but as far as we know
likely did not turn into a boy since
five told him the error in his original
time travel calculations this old five
also has the knowledge that vani is the
bomb that starts the apocalypse and that
eyeball thing is a total red herring
yeah that's a waste of time trust me
then there's the sparrow academy itself
it's comprised of seven individuals just
like the umbrella academy however there
are some
key differences worth noting other than
the obvious
sparrow emblem rather than an umbrella
the sparrow academy has
seven different members with the
exception of ben remember that reginald
in this timeline got to meet and dislike
pretty much
all the members of the umbrella academy
in the 60s so it stands to reason that
he chose
seven different children than them to
raise he also never met
ben since he was a ghost so that
explains why he was chosen
these members also have different
abilities for example one can turn into
a murder of crows and another can pass
on self-inflicted pain
onto others there's also this floating
green cube which i'm guessing is like
this academy's version of ben but
instead of being a ghost it's some sort
of consciousness put into it if these
sparrow academy members
are indeed different characters
altogether that could potentially mean
that there are
doppelgangers of the umbrella academy
who were never raised by reginald
still out there in the world i could
definitely see a scenario where those
characters become the villains next
season
and it's up to the two academies to join
forces to take them on
and it would be kind of fun to see them
take on alternate versions of themselves
and see how those versions would have
grown up had they not been taken in by
reginald
in the comics the sparrow academy
revealed themselves to the umbrella
academy and saved them from a group of
super villains
with the first two seasons revolving
around stopping the apocalypse
i think heading into a new direction
where they have a new
external threat is a welcome change next
season it looks like things are really
going to shake up for the umbrella
academy who are now at odds with the
sparrows
and a new yet to be introduced
antagonist hopefully the show will be
renewed but as of yet there's no word
but hopefully there will be soon because
we all want to know if pogo will still
be alive in this new timeline
thanks for watching everyone what did
you think of the latest season i want to
hear your comments below
and before you go make sure to leave a
like and subscribe and check out my
other videos
for more bad takes you can follow me on
twitter at thinkstoryyt
and until next time remember i'm the
daddy here